hello rejects Greg here and John here
we're gonna watch from our friends at
top five unknowns and they are friends
we're gonna watch five films - movies
that mysteriously kill people in real
life Wow Wow I don't know how that's
possible unless it's like a last action
hero kind of scenario I'm sure we're
gonna find out though sexy music five
movies that horrifyingly killed people
in real life every once in a while
you'll see a movie that really inspires
you or gets under your skin while for
most of us that means we become cheerful
or depressed for the rest of the day
there are people out there who let their
emotions rule the show and their
emotions are not what you are I
considered to be constructive or
positive in a way possible these five
now iconic movies have affected the
matter yeah a show there are several
mentally on edge folks these cinematic
features cause them to kill or die
themselves number five Twilight what why
this vampire romance series exploded
overnight it seemed like while most of
the fans were comprised of overzealous
12 year olds there were a few older
people who enjoyed this franchise enter
a middle-aged will host of a man who
lived in newsela and decided he wanted
to see the movie one evening he traveled
to the theater
got his ticket and sat down for the 6:00
p.m. showing okay only he didn't get up
again after the movie ended after the
rest of the crowd had cleared out an
employee of the theater found the man
dead in his seat what police quickly
arrived on the scene despite an in-depth
investigation nobody could figure out
why the man had died puzzled by the
mysterious death by many New Zealanders
waited to hear the results of the man's
autopsy but the results were never made
public and never discussed again a
minute the whole thing has some folks
wondering did the man become inspired to
die in the hopes of returning as a
vampire or was the movie so lousy he
died of boredom probably likely never
No Wow to die at Twilight yeah that's
this day man I haven't heard the other
ones that should be number one [ __ ] I
wonder was sad to die during that film
I'm all filmer God see now I really want
to know what this guy's life was like
because like did he come out now I want
to know why he came out to see this
movie because like how reclusive was he
did he go to movies ever or was he like
today is the day yeah I'm going out
today I'm gonna do it at Twilight I mean
he went out alone yeah who goes who's an
adult male that goes out alone to watch
Twilight yeah I mean I go to movies
alone sometimes but I wouldn't know
anyone like him and if you say you know
proud is such a horrible film that's the
worst way to die there yeah I wouldn't
want to die during a better film if I
had to die during if I were to die
during a film I would want to die maybe
during like I would I don't have to be
like I'm not done no I got nothing I
don't know if I was to die in a movie I
want to be either like a like a revival
screening of something I really love or
like some movie I've been like super
duper looking forward to the Passion of
the Christ Passion of Christ
- right when Jesus finally dies you die
what does he say when he does it's in
his time or something that's done forgot
what he says I am finished now would be
perfect if I could die right when the
movies done like right when the credits
start rolling and then the people who
made the film or disrespected because I
didn't stick around to the end the
credits plus you miss the post credit
scene The Passion of the Christ
- speaking out compared to film hitch
theaters it wasn't that uncommon to see
whole family sprinting out of the
building with tears in their eyes
afterwards Jim Caviezel dear Jesus
Christ and is seen in during the brutal
treatment Jesus was resurrected - but it
would seem that God did not appreciate
this take on human history it's reported
that Caviezel was
literally struck by lightning while they
filmed a scene by a tree but that's not
all once an employee for ABC News a
woman named Peggy Lord decided to see
the film in theaters
so apparently conservative Peggy had no
idea that the movie depicted so much
gore and violence she was overcome with
emotion and shock had another show by
the time the scene of the crucifixion
happened Peggy couldn't handle any more
she succumbed to a heart attack as the
scene took place and died within minutes
I take back badge oh wow yeah along with
the wayward lining bolt assigns from
above that God did not approve of the
stylings of this most controversial film
number three oh boy okay so I was
totally joking no I know that was a real
scenario actually happened take that I I
take that back I'm asking for Laurie in
this see this is a great this is a great
experience because you know we made a
joke and then we were given a little bit
more to chew on and now we're going back
and we're revising yeah our thought
process that was not perhaps the best to
make but it's okay we're learning it's
weird that when you make a joke then you
find it really happens you realize how
horrible the situation actually makes
you a little more conscious going
forward when that movie came out because
we were in Catholic school at the time
when that came out I movie inspired me
to go to church more I would go to
church after class I remember that yeah
yeah I would go by myself
3:00 p.m. pray to Jesus and now tis a
good time I remember hearing a story
about someone who loved who was so moved
by that movie that they like confessed
they went to the police station and
confessed to a murder while I work they
felt so guilty about it I think on the
end it did save some lives or got some
type of retribution or justice done yeah
that's too bad they didn't have a red
band trailer for pastor the Christ for
Caillou didn't know that see that's the
thing is I am a little surprised that
she didn't because it was that the her
eating raw of it yeah like this is all
about Jesus being tortured for 12 hours
yeah the second that movie came out that
was what everyone was talking about you
know like it didn't seem like anybody
didn't know how intense that movie was
gonna be cause so bad
Oh Myers so
yeah oh you can't watch passion to
Christ by yourself in a theater gotta go
a lease with like a priest and a nun you
know free few friends get some beers
yeah get some beers feel really bad
about my gosh do you like popcorn during
my crunch bites in there hey that guy
exists you know there was one of
nobodies rial yes hey man I'm eatin
popcorn during some questionable does
miss the damned when most people think
about this less than a shame home for
the dam they think about Aaliyah and her
most untimely death in an airplane crash
in 2001 but aleeah's death had nothing
to do with this mediocre sequel to the
film interview with the vampire in this
installment the notoriously Lestat
becomes acquainted with an ancient
vampire queen played by Aaliyah one day
Tom Mackendrick asked his buddy Alan
Menzies if you wanted to come over to
his house to watch the movie Alan was so
enamored with the movie and the vampire
queen
he has Tom if he could borrow it Alan
then proceeded to watch the movie
hundreds of times ah can to tell friends
and family that the vampire queen
started to visit him at night and speak
to him I heard about this yeah I have to
become a convert that the vampire queen
wanted Alan to become immortal by
killing someone for her Alan decided he
would have to find someone to kill it
was soon after when Tom made the poor
choice of insulting the vampire queen in
the movie Alan became enraged and hit
him over the head
Oh No please a job Alan then stepped on
multiple tongue Oh in his blood and
consumed half of the man's head ah
not long after Alan was trying to
convicted for murder why pulled himself
in prison number two I think it's safe
to say that film had an effect on
certain people yeah it's work that's
unfathomable oh my that would be a cool
movie though thou all joking aside I
mean he's not joke hmm
had to proceed with the topic of death
without being too offensive I mean that
would be an interesting film because the
film was a failure on many accounts
box-office critical audience reception
one man loved it so much
countless times that influenced him
where he thought he saw was it like to
hurry when you thought you saw like alia
you thought about hiring the damned in
how crazy this guy must have had some
kind of mental disorder like uh then why
very clear and that's exactly has I had
to me something was wrong there he took
it home watched it hundreds of times
claimed that she was coming to him
speaking to and it compelled him to kill
somebody
yes I mean I could get it because when I
saw The Human Centipede the amount of
people I kidnapped and created a human
centipede out of you know that's why
it's just you and I on the channel now
he was the only one I couldn't get we
know we got Briana widened Andrews
incentive P and cyber dance ELISA it was
crazy
then I had that mental breakdown a few
months ago when I was like not Ryan
Wright anymore I'm Greg Alba I was
partially related to the head yeah you
know just running up eat my head it's a
real-life lion right is getting out of
control
when you just start doing something
about it's hard when Centipede in people
gives you a sense of purpose
yeah it was worse than that that was
they stopped following me on Twitter oh
yeah that's that's a harsh harsh can
file is a--
cuz she can't it was for fun his
channels has been taking a downhill this
is that this is horrible
anyway yeah this guy is crazy that's his
[ __ ] insane I've never heard of a
film doing that before where someone
sees the fictional character they
believe it and they act upon it because
some guy insulted this like fictional
character I mean I imagine that he
probably knew a bully is death and I
don't know I'd have affected him in some
way where he kind of had some kind of
split personality breakdown or something
either way I will be in no movie to
watch I would I would I would like to
see I think a your for bloom house talk
to Jason Blum I don't know that that
Boeing Cortez no tell blew me call Queen
of the goddamned know we're not doing it
American Psycho who doesn't have a movie
about a crazy stockbroker from the 80s
American Psycho became a cult favorite
Batman and Joker theatres while some
viewers were equally entertained and
sickened by Christian Bale's character
there was some who found him to be a bit
too perfect 14 year old Michael
Hernandez was an ordinary albeit rather
nerdy young man he admired many
superheroes and some not so savory
characters such as Hannibal Lecter and
bales Patrick Bateman in American Psycho
one afternoon Michael decided he wanted
to be like Patrick and attacked and
killed one of his classmates at school
well questioned both admitted that
Michael showed signs of mental
instability long before the murder
occurred
Michael was tried and whisked off to
prison number one Wow 14 years old
that's why it has to be 17 or older what
fourteen-year-old brains are just too
influential that easily influenced uh
John no John listen
according to statistics 95% of people
who are under the age of 17 that watch
an r-rated movie commit a violent crime
that's right that's a that's at three
amigos logistics org you will see that
that is an actual statistic I'm glad
that organization exists yes tell us
these things taking from a wide variety
of hundreds of kids totally just to get
a survey done in the nation you need
take it up hundreds children who know
the future so those results will last
you I mean they all got paid $75 to
watch and already hmm trying to make
like really dark situations that is
horrible that no that seriously is Savin
the kid who he killed look look like a
really innocent kid
yeah just like those those pictures
always break my heart when they like
happy yeah and you know affable looking
these are upsetting me because these
make me wonder it's like what are the
odds what if that kid had never seen
American Psycho would it have just been
something else
probably or if that other guy hadn't
seen Queen of the Damned like what is it
just waiting for the right thing I mean
according to this video they said that
it would it was because he admired
Patrick Bateman so much and if you look
at American Psycho
definite character portrayal it's a
character study so I could see someone
becoming obsessed with who Patrick
Bateman is because even in our society
for people who love that coal film
people like quote Patrick Bateman
through the roof we all are able to
separate ourselves and know he's a
psychopath I mean if you're hit I could
see I can see someone being and you know
admiring this caiman is not like some
fat loser and Richie bones chicks he's
cut like he's all these things that you
know like a dude wants to sort of be it
was weird is that they said that prior
to this crime they didn't they say like
his parents or somebody said that he
showed clear signs of some type of
mental disorder yeah I mean they they
said that after the crime was committed
but yeah they said they noticed you know
your kid has certain signs like this you
shouldn't be showing them a film like
American psyche I mean yeah maybe he
just got his hands on him like how it's
not that hard to get a hold of a movie
maybe and if we don't know how good a
parent say like we don't know what their
supervision was like and really like
probably shitty parents it's pretty hard
to not like if you want to see a movie
in your 14 you can probably make that
happen you know if it's available that's
fair that's relatively horrified that's
why we should ban r-rated films no or
not at all ban r-rated movies maybe get
your kids some help if they're
demonstrating signs of you know like
after I saw saw mm-hmm-hmm
so many of the rejects you know like
former rejects they were on at the
beginning of this channel yeah my former
neighbor murray jeremy shine that
redhead cad das
they did not like the games I set up for
them to help them appreciate their life
and now we're not friends anyway it's
weird how people turn their back on you
when you're just having some fun yeah
it's real weird real weird don't
understand it myself let's see the
choices Natural Born Killers some movies
become so controversial
I don't create as a hardly surprising
get into trouble for their creative
freedom search was the case for Oliver
Stone Quentin Tarantino and Woody
Harrelson who rallied together to create
the film Natural Born Killers the movie
centers around two young men who become
serial killers and are then
sensationalized by the news after the
film debuted many people blamed it for a
surge in violent behavior how eighteen
year old boys were caught robbing and
killing at a bank shortly after they
watched the film the duo behind the
Colombian shootings Eric Harris and
Dylan Klebold used nbk as the codename
for their plan a 17 year old boy
proceeded to shave his head after watch
a movie then shot his mom and
half-sister while they slept that night
it's impossible to say how many murders
were inspired by this film but let's
just say there will always be those
unstable people who take the movies just
one step too far
I believe natural born killer I just
read a story that we ran site that was
about this this twelve-year-old girl and
her like 20-something boyfriend and
they're really into Natural Born Killers
and and they like murdered her parents
so that they could be together Oh God
and I think I think it said the Natural
Born Killers like their favorite movie
I just don't think Oliver Stone's films
could ever have an effect like that
again it's not as good of a filmmaker
anymore yeah that's what it's about
I'm gonna get so much crap for joking
around during this yeah you push in the
matter and tastefulness it someone
watching Bri look there's a very good
single joke people just rip me apart oh
you know handle with care
and look care there are a lot of really
interesting arguments you can have about
art and what it does to people and it's
like art doesn't I don't think art makes
people violent or makes these things
happen but you know you never know when
it's going to be the crucial piece of
stimulus that's gonna push somebody over
the edge
well there's films that are totally
opposite that have caused people to do
terrible things there was one guy who
saw Avatar thought the life would never
be as good as it was an avatar so he
killed himself Jesus I'm surprised that
wasn't included in this haven't did a
couple people died during Avatar I think
there's another guy there was a similar
sort of the Patrick the Christ one where
somebody had like a heart attack in the
theater yeah but okay like if you look
at the first story like with a Twilight
guy like that might had nothing to do
with the movie itself you know like that
guy just probably had it some type of
yeah bodily shutdown or heart attack or
some type of reaction I feel like that
story wasn't actually that crazy it's
just amusing cuz it's Twilight yeah
exactly is that like aw somebody died
during yeah yeah totally
with avatar that's pg-13 it's it's for
families made like billions of dollars
deaths have occurred from that and
someone killed himself because I thought
life was just to like we'll never be as
good as that it's not the movies problem
it's not what the movie did that's at
fault here it's yes whatever is
specifically tailored to these
individuals that have something up with
them that causes them to react a certain
way I just think it's an interesting
discussion because like you do have to
confront the fact that that's possible
because it does happen it's so I totally
yeah you know I don't think you should
censor movies or you know stop making
things just because they might fall into
the wrong hands like that's sort of a
risk you run with living but it is an
interesting thing to think about because
you kind of have to at least think about
it a little bit be like what do is there
anything we can do about this or do we
just kind of have to hope you know that
we can take better care of each other
and and you know handle our art better
in the process cuz yeah some of these
stories are [ __ ] horrifying I mean I
know this isn't a movie but when I saw
Breaking Bad you know like and this
channel start taking a dip when I came
out as Greg Alba I've had to resort to
cooking a lot of meth yeah I know you're
not very good I happy so I live I live
Van Nuys I know the mess if people get
that high off of it it's hard man I'm
listening very good at chemistry in
class I didn't finish high school um so
you got your GED yeah but you know I
didn't really just don't teach you much
about methods so when I was like I've
been having to sell meth though to make
up for the fact of this channel took a
dip and I blame it all on Breaking Bad
Brentwood only would not take
responsibility
mmm it's not that it's just really who's
that fault here and I think it's the
show yeah uh-huh yeah
for for telling you how to live your
life Hey you helped I did I did help you
helps I'm impressionable and I want to
be cool more than anything and if anyone
knows who's cool it's me got a lot of
pain deep down inside and I want to make
people pay for it know what to do with
it oh man no one cares about your pain
what helped you make a good machen ah
this is a video is it called defense
mechanisms to the real horrible things
yeah this is that like that Queen of the
Damned story like is is that the little
[ __ ] horrifying to me to the point where
yeah it's it's almost like you want to
make a joke only so that you can feel
like the world is in an awful place
what's his crazy about the Queen of the
Damned situation is it wasn't like cool
character I'm inspired it was like yes
like II think he believed it was bad
really you know yeah to watch than 800
became an obsession
that's a serious thing he probably
thought it was like his his own personal
film cuz no one's on
yo hey rejects me to the channel
subscribe today don't forget to
subscribe to top 5 unknowns they're a
fantastic channel have a lot of amazing
info filled videos John is reasons Jerry
on Twitter and Instagram he's also the
social media manager of FB comm / bloom
house and the real rejects FB Stanny for
[ __ ] bull rat oh no I like right to
exchange at [ __ ] bat know I like Batman
a lot actually [ __ ] I say [ __ ] it's
just the total let's go to one
that's just an easy one what's up ever
got any more B movies right B movie
starring Jerry Seinfeld as a B oh I
thought we were talking about like a
Salzburg kind of film Salzburg who are
those brothers and make horrible films
Oh Oh Friedberg and seltzer but those
are my creation those are like the or
those aren't I guess those are those
really Z movie and I thought they made a
movie called B movie no I don't think
that was a parody of B films man you
said that maybe this I'm getting points
lis confused this videos done Jerry
Seinfeld B movie and watching